hablamos ahora de economía aquí en
france 24 y estamos para eso con nuestra
periodista daniel hablando que nos va a
contar bien daniela bienvenida lo más
importante de hoy el acuerdo comercial
entre el parlamento europeo y el
mercosur está en la cuerda floja daniela
sí liliana muy buenas noches los mire
después de 20 años de negociaciones en
2019 se firmó este acuerdo que en la
región beneficiaría a argentina brasil
paraguay y uruguay que hacen parte del
mercosur de pero falta lo más importante
que es la aprobación parlamentaria por
el lado europeo el parlamento advirtió y
que no lo ratificará tal y como está
planeado y tiene una razón específica a
liliana que es la política ambiental del
presidente brasileño ya ir bolsonaro que
dicen riña con el acuerdo de parís algo
que naciones como francia países bajos y
austria ya habían anticipado la
eurocámara hizo una enmienda a un
documento en el que dice que si bien
esta alianza va a beneficiar a 800
millones de ciudadanos también se deben
respetar ciertas condiciones y una de
ellas es el desarrollo sostenible
pues esperemos a ver qué pasa con este
tema porque además de presidente de eeuu
considera nuevas ayudas económicas para
las aerolíneas si el presidente don
altava ha sido blanco de críticas por su
decisión de suspender las negociaciones
para un segundo paquete de estímulos
económicos por eso propuso alternativas
por ejemplo aprobar una partida de
25.000 millones de dólares para el apoyo
a la nómina de las aerolíneas y otra de
135 mil millones de dólares para el
programa de protección para pequeñas
empresas también se mostró de acuerdo
con entregar otro cheque de 1200 dólares
por familia esto dista bastante del
millonario paquete por más de 2 billones
de dólares que proponía el partido
demócrata y también de los 16 billones
que estuvo dispuesto a aprobar el
partido republicano antes de que se
suspendieran estos diálogos daniela
cuéntenos cómo es una empresa chilena
para estafar a los canadienses con
frambuesas cómo fue esto
lilian asesorías increíble mire fruti de
bosco es una comercializadora de frutas
que salió del anónimo
para protagonizar un escándalo destapado
por la agencia reuters y que se extendió
por tres continentes todo por culpa de
sus trampas una investigación de la
aduana chilena concluyó que la fruta
congelada era producida en china a muy
bajo costo de ahí llegaba a un centro de
empaquetado en santiago con la ayuda de
un intermediario en nueva zelanda
después fruto de bosco el la volví a
empacar y le ponía su sello de producto
orgánico de primera calidad cultivado en
chile finalmente se enviaba a ciudades
canadienses como montreal y vancouver
liliana para deleitar exquisitos
paladares porque eran a precios bastante
altos por ser orgánicas y además por ser
chilenas las autoridades creen que unos
12 millones de dólares en frambuesas mal
etiquetadas burlaron todos los controles
de seguridad alimentaria entre 2014 y
2016 increíble daniela y ahora cuéntenos
a finales de 2021 el mundo tendrá 150
millones de personas más en la pobreza
extrema está la estimación del banco
mundial más
ya que antes que prevee que de ese total
unos 110 millones están en el sur de
asia y en áfrica sub sahariana y que la
pobreza extrema ha subirá por primera
vez en más de dos décadas se entiende
que una persona está en la pobreza
extrema liliana cuando a su bolsillo
llega al menos de 1,90 dólares por día
este organismo multilateral estima que
una cuarta parte de los habitantes del
planeta vive con menos de 3,2 dólares
por jornada lo llamativo del nuevo
informe es que 8 de cada 10 nuevos
pobres extremos van a venir de países de
ingresos medios como india nigeria e
indolencia y muchos de ellos serán
residentes urbanos bueno ni la cuenta en
los indicadores de la jornada
bueno la esperanza se tomó wall street o
por las declaraciones de trump sobre
estímulos a las aerolíneas y sus
principales índices subieron en europa
los cambios fueron más moderados subió a
la bolsa de fráncfort por ejemplo y
parís y madrid bajaron en américa latina
méxico fue la que mejor reaccionó a los
posibles estímulos en eeuu la cifra
daniela son los 30 y 18 millones
dólares en que fue subastado en nueva
york en la esqueleto del tiranosaurio
rex están por la casa británica
christie's
esta pieza de casi 4 metros de alto y
otros 12 desde la cabeza hasta la última
vértebra de la cola quien duplicó su
precio estimado inicialmente que era de
8 millones de dólares gracias daniela
por la información de colombia ellos
ustedes gracias por estar en flash 24
continúen con más en nuestra página web
france24 puntocom nos vemos más adelante
[Música]